In this session,
we take up the peremptory strike.
That is strikes exercise by
the prosecution and by the
defense lawyers to remove
prospective jurors after,
uh,
this is not the same as
the challenges for cause.
Those challenges are based upon the
inability of a juror to be fair and
impartial,
either because of what the
juror has read or heard,
or fields or attitudes about the death
penalty or any other factor that would
keep a person from objectively
being fair and impartial.
The parties have the right
to strike a certain number,
usually set by statute.
Uh,
let's say 10,
uh,
10 jurors for any reason whatsoever.
Uh,
and for years,
the perimetry strike was used to exclude
African Americans from jury service,
uh,
in the communities where they were in,
the jury pools,
uh,
Robert Swain,
a black man was sentenced to
death and Talladega County,
Alabama,
a 26% of the population of Talladega
county was African American.
Uh,
but they were underrepresented
in the jury pools only 10 to 15%,
uh,
of the average jury pool
and no black person,
no African American had
ever served on a jury.
Uh,
in Talladega,
uh,
Robert Swayne's lawyers
presented to claims based on
the equal protection clause
of the 14th amendment
to the Supreme Court.
First of all at the prosecutor
discriminated in Swayne's
case that is in Robert
Swayne's case by striking all six black
people who were in the group of people
there for jury duty.
Uh,
and secondly that the
prosecutor regularly one,
not just in Swayne's case,
but in virtually every case,
the prosecutor struck African Americans,
uh,
from jury service and at this practice
violated the rights equal protection.
It's interesting to look
at when Swain was decided,
this is right during the midst of what's
been called the Warren Court's Criminal
Law Revolution.
Uh,
when the court was deciding cases like
Miranda versus Arizona and was trying to
do something about some of the abusive
practices that were going on and just to,
uh,
trying to provide some
procedural fairness,
uh,
in the criminal justice system.
Uh,
it also came down in the mid
1960 [inaudible] when much
of the country was still
segregated on the basis of race.
This is not that long a time period
after the court had decided brown versus
board of education requiring a
into segregation in the schools,
and there was massive resistance
to the Brown decision.
Uh,
and this is right in the midst
of the civil rights movement.
Uh,
and yet,
uh,
the court ignores the discrimination.
It was obvious that Robert Swain and then
everybody knew happened in every case.
That it was just a routine
practice for prosecutors to strike,
uh,
people on the basis of race.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the court instead celebrates
the preemptory stripe.
Uh,
it says that it can be
exercised on any grounds,
uh,
including race,
religion,
nationality,
occupation or affiliation.
Uh,
and in case that wasn't clear enough,
a lawyer may strike any group,
whether they be Negroes,
Catholics,
accounts,
or those with blue eyes.
Uh,
you can imagine that more strikes were
probably being used against black people
than people with blue eyes.
Uh,
and the court goes on to say in the
quest for an impartial and qualify jury,
Negro and white,
Protestant and Catholic are
subject to the perimetry strike.
Think of that sentence again.
In the quest for an
impartial and qualified jury,
Negro and white,
Protestant and Catholic are subject to
being struck just because of their race
or because of their religion.
Uh,
from jury service.
Well,
of course,
if you're in a minority,
uh,
if you're the black people,
and you're only six blacks in the jury
veneer from which Robert's Wayne's trial,
uh,
was chosen and the prosecution
struck you because you are black,
that's pretty much going to mean that
they're not going to be any blacks serving
on juries,
uh,
in Talladega county.
The court here makes again,
a wrong call,
uh,
in dealing with racial discrimination.
I think looking back on it now,
we can say that this is a case like
Plessy versus Ferguson or like,
uh,
the dred Scott decision or what the court
will later too in McCleskey vs Klemp
Kemp,
uh,
where the court sanctions and puts its
stamp of approval here really more than
in any other place.
The court puts its stamp of approval on
race discrimination in jury selection.
Uh,
and it continues to this day.
We'll look at what's been
done to try to stem it.
To some extent,
but I don't think anybody doubts that
when peremptory strikes are used,
where neither side has to give a reason,
that one of the primary
considerations is race,
even though it's illegal.
Uh,
the court also,
uh,
took a look at Swains claim
with regard to the systemic,
uh,
challenge the prosecutor,
striking people all the time.
Uh,
but it's set an impossible standard
to me that when the prosecutor,
in case case,
no matter what the circumstances are,
whatever what crime is,
is,
uh,
accused,
no matter who the defendant,
no matter who the victim,
uh,
if the prosecutor in every case like that
removes blacks and they don't serve on
juries at all,
uh,
it might be possible,
to conclude that the prosecution was
striking on the basis of race and denying
black people.
Jury Service Accord is
pretty stingy though.
It goes on to say such proof might support
a reasonable inference that negroes
are being excluded for reasons
wholly unrelated to the case.
And that the peremptory strike is
being used to deny black people.
Uh,
they're writing an opportunity to present,
uh,
to participate in the administrative
of administration of justice like other
people.
Uh,
but Swayne's lawyer hadn't proven,
uh,
that it was the prosecution responsible
for the fact that there had never been
an African American on a
jury and Talladega County,
Alabama.
So he fails a on that.
But when you think about
this test going forward,
it means that a prosecution
can discriminate in one case,
but unless you can prove
that over every case,
no matter who the defendant,
no matter who the victim,
no matter what the issue is in the case,
unless it's a practice across the boards,
the court holds that it doesn't
violate the equal protection clause.
Well,
uh,
the Swain case,
well let me mention the dissent.
Uh,
just as Goldberg joined by Chief Justice
Warren and Douglas a descend from this,
the court points out that
this adds additional barriers.
Uh,
we know that discrimination is going on
in the selection of jurors and instead
of doing something to try to stem
the tide to try to change it,
the court sets of burden that's almost
impossible to meet in this case.
As the court said,
uh,
or just as Goldberg said,
the court keeps the word
of promise to our ears.
Uh,
but it breaks it to our hope.
he points out that neither side
has the right to printers strike.
This is not provided
for in the constitution,
may be provided for him,
some state laws.
Uh,
but this is not a constitutional
right that's at stake here.
Uh,
and,
uh,
it's just as Marshall points out,
later on in Mcrae versus New York,
uh,
the Swain case was subject to scathing
criticism and yet it took 20 years,
uh,
before the court did anything about the
fact that this case made it perfectly
okay for a prosecutor and striking a
jury to strike people because they were
black or because they were Catholic or
because of any other characteristic that
they might have.
A,
whether or not that
changes made a difference,
uh,
is subject to,
debate.
Uh,
but in 1986,
the court modified Swain
or the standard and Swain,
uh,
still relied upon the equal protection
clause of the 14th amendment that is
intentional racial discrimination.
But said no longer is it necessary
to prove in case after case,
no matter who the victim,
no matter who the defendant,
that the prosecutor is striking,
uh,
all the blacks in every case,
you can infer a court can
infer discrimination from
a disproportionate use of
strikes in a single case.
In other words,
the prosecutors strikes,
he was 10 peremptory strikes and nine of
the strikes are against the nine black
people in the veneer.
So there's an all white jury,
the court,
and that happened all the time.
Uh,
the court says you can infer from that
race discrimination and it doesn't mean
there was,
but you can infer from that.
Uh,
and if that happened,
the judge,
the prosecutor then has to
give race neutral reasons,
uh,
has to say why I didn't strike
that man because he was black.
I struck him for some other reason.
I didn't strike that woman
because she was black.
I struck her for some other reason.
And then finally,
after the court looks at the strikes and
any other evidence that's presented on
discrimination looks at the
reasons given by the prosecutor,
the burden of proof is on the defendant,
that challenger,
uh,
to show intentional race discrimination.
And the judge decides that now what
this requires a trial judge to find is
intentional racial discrimination by a
prosecutor and that the prosecutor lied
about it by giving a pre
textual reason for the strike,
uh,
when really the reason was race a very,
very difficult psychologically,
uh,
and just practically for judges to make
that finding a many jurisdictions in
this country,
prosecutors and judges
work together all the time.
Uh,
the judges know Morgan
accuse that prosecutor of
discriminating and lying about
it,
uh,
because,
it politically it may be
impossible for one reason.
Uh,
but secondly,
they may have a relationship in which the,
the judges wouldn't do that.
Or the judge may have racial attitudes,
uh,
that,
don't find objectionable.
A striking all the blacks,
very often people go to the bench,
uh,
from having been in prosecutor's offices.
So,
uh,
may be the judge was at one time the
district attorney himself and he may have
struck all the African
Americans when picking juries.
Now he's the judge and his chief assistant
as the prosecutor and he's striking
African Americans.
Um,
but that's who the courts
look to to protect the rights
of black people to serve
on juries.
That trial judges,
uh,
there's been a tremendous
amount of resistance to Bateson,
uh,
by,
both courts and lawyers,
uh,
ever,
ever since it has been decided.
A Justice Marshall who of course
had seen race discrimination,
personal and up close,
uh,
correctly predicted in his concurring
opinion in bats and that it was not going
to prevent race discrimination,
uh,
pointed out first of all,
that because you have to show
a disproportionate number
of blacks were struck in
order to make out a prima facia case.
If the prosecution,
uh,
struck one or two blacks
because they were black,
uh,
it can get away with that because that
doesn't establish a prima facia case.
It's only when it's something,
like I said,
nine out of 10.
So there are only a few
African Americans in the jury.
The prosecutors strikes him.
Maybe the reason is because they're black,
but we'll never know
because in those cases,
the prosecutor probably won't
be asked to give reasons.
Secondly,
he points out that any prosecutor,
uh,
can,
assert a facially neutral reasons and the
tragedies aren't going to know whether
those reasons are true or not.
And so they're not going to be able to
second guess the prosecutor with regard
to the reasons.
Thirdly,
he points out what the Supreme
Court had recognized in Turner,
uh,
that a prosecutor's conscious or
unconscious racism might very well be the
reason that he's striking head juror,
that he might see a black person and
think that that juror is salon or distant.
Uh,
but he might see a white juror
who acts exactly the same way,
but he doesn't have that same,
uh,
feeling,
about the jurors.
These demeanor reasons,
saying that jurors didn't pay attention
or that they appeared uncomfortable or
all sorts of things
that they were selling.
A,
those are reasons that
prosecutors give all the time,
uh,
for striking African Americans.
Uh,
and it's virtually impossible for judges
to know whether they're true or not.
In the litigation over,
uh,
the use of a peremptory
strikes and North Carolina,
it was actually discovered that the
prosecutors had a list of race neutral
reasons,
so that if they had struck a juror
and they had to give a reason,
they could just look down and say,
well,
that juror was solid.
Uh,
so it didn't necessarily have to
relate to the particular juror.
It was just a race neutral reason,
uh,
that was available,
I should say bats and
now applies to everyone.
It applies in civil cases to
plaintiffs and defendants,
lawyers.
Uh,
it applies to defense
lawyers and criminal cases.
Uh,
but still where it comes up
most often is in prosecutors,
uh,
striking African Americans,
from jury service.
And we'll look a little
more at that in a moment.
Uh,
but here the court starts basically
cutting back on this and Hernandez versus
New York,
the prosecutor struck for Latinos
because they could speak Spanish.
And prosecutor's reason was that they
would not trust the interpreter if they're
Spanish speaking.
People on the witness stand,
uh,
these Latinos would understand what they
were saying and he didn't want anybody
to understand where they were saying
he wanted people to only go by what the
interpreter said.
A supreme court says,
first of all,
the fact that it has a discriminatory
impact because this reason of course
applied only to Latinos
that spoke Spanish.
So it meant that they were
excluded from the jury.
Uh,
secondly,
the fact that a reason
correlates with race,
uh,
does not,
mean that it's an impermissible.
It can still be a race neutral reason,
even though it may result in all the,
in this case Latinos or in another case,
all the blacks being excluded.
A third,
the court talks about
deference to the trial judge,
uh,
reversed only if clearly erroneous.
So it's going to be very
difficult for a defendant,
uh,
who makes us challenge
to a prosecutor's strike.
And the trial judge rejects that
and lets the black juror sins,
the watch your home,
it's going to be very difficult to get
that reversed because of this clearly
erroneous standard.
Uh,
justice Stevens,
uh,
joined by Justice Marshall,
would have found,
uh,
discrimination,
in the case,
uh,
not long after that,
the court decides per cat versus him.
In 1995,
uh,
here,
some people wondered if Batson really
meant anything at all because the court
said,
uh,
prosecutor in this case struck to blacks.
Uh,
he said those two African Americans
were the only people in the whole jury
veneer that had facial hair,
mustache and goatee and one and
one of them had long curly hair.
And he didn't strike them
because they were black.
He struck them because they had beards.
And because the one had long curly hair,
uh,
the case got reversed below.
The Supreme Court says,
that's acceptable reasons.
Uh,
the reason need not be
persuasive or even plausible.
It can even be silly.
You're superstitious,
uh,
as long as it's not based on race.
Now that doesn't mean that the court
can't still find discrimination.
Uh,
at step three of the bats and process
step one being the defendant raises the
objection and says,
your honor,
I object.
The prosecutor just struck that juror
and I believe it's on the basis of race.
And I would ask the PR,
the judge not to allow that as step one.
Step two,
the prosecutor says,
your honor,
I didn't strike that juror based on race.
I struck that juror because he had long
curly hair and he had a mustache and
goatee.
Then at the third step,
the court considers all of that
evidence and decides whether there was
intentional racial discrimination.
Uh,
this case certainly,
uh,
said that the reasons don't
have to be very persuasive.
Uh,
silly.
You're superstitious.
But it did say maybe they wouldn't
be persuasive at that third step,
but that's up to the trial judge.
A court finds that there is no bats in
violation here with the strikes of these
African Americans.
Uh,
just as a and briar a dissent,
uh,
they would find,
discrimination in this particular case.
So,
uh,
what's the impact of Batson?
Uh,
we know that in Philadelphia and not
long after Batson came out or prosecutor
was conducting a training session and
he basically spent most of it telling
people how to consider race
in making jury strikes,
uh,
after the supreme court had just said
that it violates the equal protection
clause to do so.
Uh,
the Illinois Court of Appeals says,
when it gets to the
Batson issue in a case,
we now come to the charade called Bateson.
Uh,
surely every prosecutor's office has
a manual or a list of Handy Dandy race
neutral reasons,
uh,
that it can,
give.
And of course we know that's
true because in North Carolina,
uh,
it actually came out in evidence that
there was such a handy dandy list of race
neutral reasons that were being used,
um,
and made up before the
prosecutor ever saw the jurors,
uh,
and knew what to object about.
Uh,
and then we see these cases
out of Louisiana where the
Louisiana Supreme Court
says that bear statistics alone is not
enough to establish a prima facia case,
which seems completely
contradictory to Batson,
which said,
disproportionate number of strikes in
the defendant's case could be a basis for
inferring race discrimination.
Uh,
but the Louisiana court
now in a number of cases,
even one where the
prosecution used 11 strikes,
10 of them against blacks,
nine of them against women.
The court says there's
no prime aphasia case.
There's no need for the
prosecutor to even give reasons.
A,
because no prime aphasia case,
uh,
has been established.
Uh,
Louisiana has been a one
of many jurisdictions,
which is almost never have the appellate
courts found a of bats in violation.
One case where the prosecutor
said he struck someone,
uh,
because he was a young black male,
that case did get reversed,
but that was pretty obvious.
Uh,
that person had not gotten the a handy
dandy list of race neutral reasons and
didn't know that you couldn't give
ray a racist and explicit reason.
But for the most part,
uh,
state supreme courts to deferring to
trial judges and trial judges are very
reluctant to reverse or to
say that prosecutors are
intentionally discriminating
and are not telling the truth about it.
The practice continues
and case after case,
uh,
but some cases had been reversed and
some of them are quite extraordinary.
The middle or case out of Texas Thomas
Middle [inaudible] who was sentenced to
death in Dallas and who
had a Swain hearing that is
under Swain versus Alabama.
He wanted to show that the prosecutors
in Dallas in case after case,
no matter who the defendant,
no matter who the victim,
that they had a pattern and practice
of striking people of color.
Well then the Batson decision came down.
So the court took that evidence as well
as the evidence of the strikes and the
particular case trial judge
in Houston and Dallas,
excuse me,
the trial judge in Dallas,
no problem.
No race discrimination,
court of criminal appeals,
no race discrimination,
federal court and the United States
Court of Appeals for the fifth circuit.
No race discrimination.
But the supreme court sees it differently.
And look at the facts
that had decided on a,
the DA's office had a formal
policy of striking blacks.
It had a manual that said to
strike blacks when picking jurors.
Uh,
it trained had testimony from people who
had been in the prosecutor's office at
the time.
Miller else case was tried that said
we were trained to strike blacks.
Uh,
when we pick the jury.
also it was obvious in the
transcript of the jury selection,
which went on for some time here that
the prosecutor questioned black jurors
differently than white jurors.
The prosecution even use
some trick questions to try
to disqualify black jurors
but didn't ask those same questions,
uh,
of white jurors.
Texas has some very unusual
practice called the jury shuffle,
where the jurors are all,
uh,
shuffle that is,
they're put in a different order to,
to sit.
Uh,
and anytime that blacks
would be near the front,
the prosecution would call for a jury
shuffle and hopes that the blacks would be
moved further back.
But then what was probably most critical
was what justice Souter called a side
by side comparisons that the prosecution
had excepted whites who had the same
characteristics of blacks that
the prosecutor had struck.
In other words,
there's no real difference between
these jurors except for their race.
Uh,
and for that reason,
uh,
justice Souter a writing for the court
finds that even under the deference that
the Texas Court of criminal appeals,
which had decided this
case on direct appeal,
even with the deference that was required
under the antiterrorism and effective
death penalty act,
that is that in applying Batson
it had to be contrary to,
or an unreasonable application
of the Batson decision.
That there was a constitutional violation
here and there was discrimination and
the selection of Thomas Miller L's trial
and he's entitled to a new trial with a
fairly,
uh,
select a jury.
Uh,
three justices dissented,
justice Thomas,
chief justice Rehnquist
and Justice Scalia.
But a lot of people have said that's
an extraordinary case because of the
manual,
the training,
the policy,
all those things in Dallas.
Uh,
what about the more typical case,
uh,
where you don't have that
kind of overwhelming evidence?
Well,
Snyder versus Louisiana was a
case that came on direct appeal,
uh,
not a habeas corpus case,
but Snyder was convicted
in Jefferson parish,
Louisiana where the prosecutor's
office had a long history of striking,
uh,
black people from juries.
In fact,
a group of ministers in Jefferson parish
filed a friend of the court brief with
the supreme court that basically said,
we're just not a part of the jury system
here because we're always excluded.
Uh,
because of the prosecution's
use of strikes.
A Alan Snyder's case was no different.
Uh,
there were five African Americans
that were in the jury pool.
Jefferson parish at that time
had about 15% African Americans.
Uh,
it had been represented in
the legislature by David Duke,
the,
uh,
the grand wizard of the Klu Klux Klan.
I did voted for Duke when he ran for
governor in the United States senator.
Uh,
and so it wasn't a really good place
for an African American to be on trial.
Uh,
and particularly with an all white jury.
The case centered around a
student named Jeffrey Brooks,
who had said that he needed to get back
to school for his student teaching.
Uh,
but then when the dean was called,
it was told that it was okay
that he could serve on this case.
This case only took about three days,
day and a half for jury selection
day and a half for trial.
And Alan Snyder was on death row.
Uh,
what,
uh,
the court found was that
while Brooks was struck,
while Jeffrey Brooks was struck,
the prosecutor had accepted white people,
uh,
as jurors including one in Ronald laws,
who had a far more urgent reason to
get back to what they were doing.
Laws had to close on two
houses that he was selling,
one the next weekend and
one the weekend after that,
his wife was having surgery and he was
having to take his children everywhere.
If there was anybody who
wouldn't want to be on a jury,
it would be laws.
Uh,
and yet he was accepted and served on
the jury and Jeffrey Brooks was struck.
Uh,
so,
uh,
prosecution use five for five,
only one is examined by the Supreme Court.
Uh,
Jeffrey Brooks,
the court says there was intentional
race discrimination in striking Brooks,
uh,
and therefore Snyder,
it gets a new trial.
Uh,
well,
uh,
the discrimination continues,
in the selection of juries
and particularly in the
use of peremptory strikes.
A trial judges very reluctant to find,
uh,
intentional race discrimination
for political reasons,
for relationship reasons
and for other reasons.
Uh,
secondly,
procedural rules,
uh,
you see often courts
rejecting that some claims,
even though the,
uh,
defendant's lawyer can point to side by
side comparisons like we're made in the
Miller l case,
here's a black person who was struck
and a white person with the same
characteristics who was not struck.
Uh,
and uh,
therefore it shows racist combination.
A lot of times.
Now the courts are saying,
well,
you didn't say that at the
trial at the time you objected.
Of course at that time,
it's sometimes hard to know
the characteristics of all
the jurors if there's a
large number of people being
considered a for jury service,
but very strict procedural
rules to try to defeat,
uh,
these,
claims,
uh,
reluctance of state supreme courts.
Again,
most states,
supreme court's not all,
but most are elected.
Certainly the ones in the south
and the death belt are elected.
Uh,
and there is reluctance there,
uh,
to grant relief in any capital case.
But certainly based on jury selection,
I think many people may think it jury
would have convicted no matter what.
But we all know that who participates
in a jury is critically important for a
lot of reasons,
both in terms of the quality
of the decisions that are made,
but others that I'll mention in a moment.
The other factor of the clearly erroneous,
uh,
standard,
which means that state supreme
courts can often just simply,
uh,
ignore,
or,
or can affirm what the
trial court has done,
uh,
saying,
well,
we may not agree with it,
but we don't think it raises to the
rises to the level where it was clearly
erroneous.
The other thing that we've seen a lot
of courts do is accept multiple reasons
where in one case,
the prosecutors,
first reason was he struck a juror
because she was a black woman.
But then he went on to give some
other reasons and the court said,
well,
the first reason was a race based reason,
but the other reasons we're not
and therefore it was upheld.
So,
uh,
as a result,
the incentive to prosecutors is give as
many reasons as you possibly can give
four or five six it surely one of them
is going to pass muster as a race neutral
reason.
On the other hand,
some,
uh,
some courts have said the fact that the
prosecutor gives the laundry list of
reasons may be a indicia of
race discrimination right there.
So that's still to be sorted
out by the Supreme Court.
One of the other questions to
be sorted out as this Louisiana,
uh,
Supreme Court decisions that you haven't
made out a prime aphasia case just by
showing a disparate number of strikes
against African Americans or women.
Uh,
but for the most part,
uh,
discrimination,
continues.
That's an objections are made.
They're very seldom sustained.
That is usually the prosecution is
going to get away with striking,
uh,
the people of color from the jury.
Uh,
justice briar has suggested that it may
be time to abolish peremptory strikes
this,
as mentioned from time to time,
just as Goldberg pointed out way
back in Swain versus Alabama,
there's no right to a peremptory strike.
And if you've got to choose between
racist combination of peremptory strike,
you should choose to eliminate race
discrimination just as Marshall and his
concurring opinion in Bateson said,
if we really want to prevent this,
Batson is not going to work.
What we decided in this case,
if we really want to present,
prevent race discrimination,
we need to eliminate peremptory strikes.
Uh,
once more,
uh,
Justice Marshall,
I think,
uh,
got,
got it right.
Uh,
but beyond that,
Batson is a very poor way to
deal with what is a practice,
a regular practice taking one juror at,
at time.
And looking at the reason for that juror
sort of takes it out of the context of
what's going on in case after case.
Uh,
with prosecutors,
a lot of times now the prosecution will
leave one African American on the jury,
or maybe even too,
particularly if in a state where you
don't have to have unanimous verdict,
uh,
but we'll still end up striking a
lot of people on the basis of color.
Uh,
I tell lawyers it's like a lottery,
a buy your ticket,
make her objection point out the side
by side comparisons point out that the
black jurors were questioned
differently than the white jurors.
Uh,
all of those things challenged the
reasons given because a lot of the reasons
and one of the reasons given for striking
Jeffrey Brooks and the Snyder case was
he was nervous.
Well,
the lawyers said,
well,
everybody's nervous.
I mean,
you brought all these people down here
to decide whether to kill another human
being.
Uh,
everybody's nervous.
I'm nervous,
we're all nervous.
And it was a way of sort
of basically saying this,
this reason,
then the plot applies to everybody.
So there's no reason to strike,
uh,
Jeffrey Brooks,
but ultimately the continuing
exclusion of people of color,
uh,
from juries,
even in communities that have very
substantial African American population,
uh,
is undermining the credibility
and the legitimacy of the courts.
One of the things that was stated in
Snyder brief was that African Americans in
Jefferson parish,
Louisiana,
and know that they are not going to
serve on juries and it undermines their
respect for the courts and nothing
the white people know it too.
And the fact is that when the
community is not all involved,
when you don't have everybody
in the community represented,
and when one group is
targeted for exclusion,
as tragically continues to be the place,
the case in many places today,
uh,
it undermines the quality of decision
making by the courts and the legitimacy
and credibility of those courts.